remember East Palestine Ohio terrible
chemical spill
and what did the federal government say
they said oh it's fine it's fine now
don't look at all the glistening
rainbows in the water that are obviously
from chemicals don't don't worry about
how you're coughing and you're getting
sick no no we tested it the air is fine
the water's fine nothing to see here
move along move along so finally Federal
investigators have gone down to
investigate Ohio
and they have found out that half of the
crew from just a little under half of
the crew from the CDC
has gotten sick members of the epidemic
intelligence service began feeling
symptoms while surveying Town residence
homes near contaminated areas so the
federal government comes in and they say
oh it's fine there's no problem here
don't worry you come down here oh okay
that's fine and then half the crew gets
sick they say oh yeah well no that's
probably just a coincidence anyway Move
Along
Move Along